The Avengers endgame trailer has finally
hit the internet and whilst it does a
great job of recapping where we last
left our heroes at the end of infinity
war
it also has six minor hints out where
the movie could go throughout this video
I'll be discussing the six minor details
that you probably missed from the
trailer and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on if there was anything you
spied without the way and definition and
welcome to the channel where I roon it
so you don't have to number six the
quantum realm van ant-man makes a
hilarious entrance in the trailer but
there's something else that his arrival
has implications for the van he arrives
in is clearly Louisa's from the ant-man
movies and those who've seen ant-man and
the wasp will remember that in the back
of it is the quantum tunnel this device
allows people to travel into the quantum
realm and will most likely be the method
that the heroes used to travel in time
to the Battle of New York number five
Thor's new AI in the trailer we get a
very minor shot of Thor sitting with his
new AI fans will remember that rocket
gifted him this an infinity war but in
this trailer something doesn't sit right
about it a lot of people have predicted
that the character will go back to his
eye patch for the preceding films as
this eye may be malfunctioning it's
something I love to see and definitely a
character choice that hope they go with
number four the Winter Soldier suit
Captain America is featured pretty
heavily in the trailer and so is his
strike suit from the Winter Soldier film
this was the first MCU movie that the
Russo brothers directed and could be
symbolic of the fact that everything is
coming full circle with them as this is
reportedly the last Marvel film they
will be directing it will be interesting
to see if it ties into caps fate and I
can't wait to see if this is symbolic of
something in the movie number 3 Sheree
is dead at the end of infinity war
series fate was unknown however the end
game trailer pretty clearly confirms
that she was killed during the snap in a
blink in you'll miss a moment Bruce
Banner is staring out a list of people
believed to be killed in the snap and
Sherry's face flashes up on the monitor
her before being replaced by Pierre Park
number two nebula warms while some
people pretty clearly believe that tawny
is on the ship alone
it's definitely clear on re-watched that
nebula is accompanying him and there are
several shots that tease this another
interesting one showcases that nebula is
still curved about the loss of her
sister in one shot nebula is seen
staring at her sisters sea and even
strokes it it makes it even more
heartbreaking to know that Gamora may
not even return as her death happened
before the snap so she could be lost
forever
number one the age of Ultron Easter Egg
in the trailer we see Tony reach out to
touch his mask in a very sad moment this
is a callback to the age of Ultron
trailer in which Ultron did a very
similar motion movie Webb stated that in
Avengers age of Ultron
Tony created Ultron who was essentially
an evil version of himself in order to
prevent what he described as the end
game now that the end game has started
Tony needs to be his own Ultron I
absolutely loved this theory and think
that it definitely holds a lot of weight
and can't wait to see what comes from it
so is there anything that you noticed in
the trailer and what did you think of my
list comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then make sure
you like it and check out my fan
theories on the trailer which we linked
at the end of this one this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]